i want people to cut loose i want people
making out in classes
i want people hanging from the ceilings
lampshades on the heads i want it to be
a playboy mansion party and also i want
you to know and spread the word that i
will have my digital camera and i'll be
taking pictures all along the way and
the best and craziest thing that happens
will be on the cover of the newsletter
incentive you do realize that we can't
serve liquor at the party yeah i know
damn it
stupid corporate wet blankets like booze
ever killed anybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
all right
[Music]
one two three
[Music]
you're welcome merry christmas no wait
oh you're kidding me pekka
yes
you're ladies and gentlemen
what's up my nerds check it out no
oh look at that icing on the cake
pacman need a drink oh let's fix you up
who wants to fix up toby toby's gonna
fix
[Music]
whose butt is that
mine oh how did i not guess
[Music]
hey oh
hello there
what are you doing i don't know
you shouldn't do things like that
the man is supposed to do that
[Music]
this is equal parts scotch absinthe rum
gin vermouth triple sec and two packs of
splenda call it a one of everything
oh
my
god
hit me again all right
hey meredith heading over to port
richards yep
cool cool cool
you need a ride
all right let's head out
sounds good you have a coat
yeah oh
okay
[Music]
what do you
fruity and think see i told you you want
meredith no thanks
they're too sweet
hey so what's the status it looks like
they forgot the power cord what are you
kidding me no oh god you guys guys um
i'm sorry but there's a problem with the
karaoke machine
that blows hang on little ladies you
don't need this thing i'll go grab my
synthesizer
[Applause]
[Music]
hi hey
hey look when you get done with your
meeting you should uh come to the break
room we're having a party oh okay all
right
see y'all
[Music]
these nuts are really hard to crack
try harder then
ah no one has seconds until everyone's
had some
you've got to be kidding
you've got to be kidding
cold huh
that'll help
the cold in
there and i'm here
to remind you
of the mess you left when you went away
it's not fair
to deny me
of the cross i bear that
[Music]
ryan kevin phyllis oscar come and take
these shots yes
we'll do
the fifth one is for you aaron you could
take it or leave it
to take it would be to accept that
you're at a party and you're an adult
woman
you live an adventurous spirit
to leave it would be fine too one two
three yes okay
timmy christmas
christmas indeed
hit her up oh yes yeah
wow
[Music]
120 180
200. all right oh thank you so much my
daughter is gonna love this oh so glad i
could help thanks merry christmas you
too
i don't ask for much for christmas i
really don't
it's not like i am begging people to
buy me diamonds and
broach
pendants
oh
buy me something expensive or i'm going
to kill myself that's not
i don't care about that all i want to be
is santa
and
you want to take that away from me
fine
go ahead
but when you need my help because i am
ruining everything don't look at me
that's great
behold
jesus christ
[Applause]
walk a lonely road only one that i have
ever known
don't know where it goes but it's all to
me when i walk alone
it's true
we all walk alone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh 12 drummers drumming
[Music]
merry christmas erin
take it away boys
never this garbage
[Music]
this is christmas
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
you